كاد ان يعتزل قبل 18 شهرا لكنه وجد نفسه
وجد نفسه الحارس الاساسي في مونديال قطر
هذه قصه حارس منتخب هولندا وهي من قصص
المونديال الكثيره منها مفاجاه ومنها
غريبه واخرى مؤلمه فراحله الحارس اندريس
نوبرت صاحب 28 عاما نحو قطر كانت مذهله
فعلا وكادت هذه المسيره ان تنتهي لولا
اسراره على المواصله في سبيل تحقيق حلمه
في كره القدم وفي تفاصيل القصه انه قبل
ثلاث سنوات كان لوبرت حارسا احتياطيا في
فريقيا في القسم الثالث الايطالي حيث
ارتكب الكثير من الاخطاء التي جعلته لا
يظهر الا نادرا ليجد نفسه في نهايه عام
2019 بدون اذن لكنه وقع مع نادي دور درفت
القابع في الدرجه الهولنديه الثانيه في
عام 2020 الا انه عاده وفسخ عقده خمسه
اشهر فقط بسبب سوء المستوى الذي قدمه
اندرياس نو بارتي حراسه مرمى الفريق ثم
توجه الى نادي جو اهاد ايجلز وشارك معه في
لقاء واحد طوال موسم كروي كامل ما دفعه
لترك النادي ليصبح مره اخرى بدون فريق هنا
زاد وضعه النفسي سواء سوءا فعليا ودفعه
التفكير في انهاء مسيرته الكرويه والتفكير
بوظيفه ضابط شرطه لكن المفاجاه حصلت عندما
اعطاه مدرب فريق
الهولندي فرصه وامن بقدرته حيث كان حاضرا
في 14 لقاءا وجنب فريقه الهبوط للدرجه
الثانيه هذا التالق الكبير جذب انظار مدرب
منتخب هولندا لويس فانغال الذي استدعاه
للمعسكر التحضيري لمنتخب الطواحين قبل بدء
المونديال يبتسم له الحظ اخيرا ويشد نفسه
نوفمبر من عام 2022 اساسيا في نهائيات كاس
العالم بقطر اذا هذا اللاعب قدم اداء
كبيرا ومبهرا امام السنغال في اولى
مباريات المنتخب الهولندي في مونديال قطر
وغالبا سيبقى الرقم واحد في شباك الطواحين
بعد ادائه اللافت هذا